the Joe Rogan experience they said he
was a CI it was before Eddie was deep
deep deep deep deep in the conspiracies
back then it was like he was Beryl he
was like in the UFOs and [ __ ] it was
barely any conspiracies he's way off the
deep end you got me into UFOs well maybe
it is true I'm uh I'm scheduled to have
a phone call today this afternoon with
George Knapp he wants to brief me all
the [ __ ] George Knapp is the guy that
broke the Bob Lazar story in the 1990s
yeah and you know he shares my opinion
he's like most of this is [ __ ] most
these people are liars most these people
are crazy but there's some real [ __ ] out
there too like a lot of these Air Force
pilots that they have eyes on this
[ __ ] thing that's going 600 miles
away in a second like dropping down from
60,000 feet to 10 feet like in a second
ya know like I don't know we don't know
what the [ __ ] this is we have no idea
how these things are doing right and
that's not some hillbilly like just no
talking about SAS exactly though yeah
it's Air Force pilots people who they're
trained to fly jets and have gunfights
in the [ __ ] sky right these are
exceptional human beings yeah when they
see things like that you gotta go they
know what the [ __ ] they're seeing that's
so crazy yeah who knows the thing is
like every day you could go out there
and look in the sky you don't see [ __ ]
you know if there's nothing up there
because you're not seeing it but if you
go to a [ __ ] Lake you're never gonna
see a shark you know I'm saying right
like it doesn't mean sharks aren't real
it's like you're looking in the wrong
spot or you won't you aren't there when
they show up but they're real so we have
enough accumulated data to know that all
there are sharks you know they are real
but they're not in lakes there in the
ocean here's where they are this is how
you find them go to South Africa oh look
there's a shark oh yeah oh yeah or um
[ __ ] Catalina of Catalina
I'd say Tom yeah I worked at a Boy Scout
camp in Catalina and I was teaching
snorkelling and that was like the whole
time I was [ __ ] myself oh my god
it's just the nicest water in the world
though it's so warm and salty it's yeah
you just float you know we did Fear
Factor out there a couple times
really yeah we did a couple of stunts my
hello water stands here it's a cool spot
we stand on the other side like the
hotels on the one side
everything we were on the other side
campsites it was awesome awesome I was
like 13 and I got so roasted my entire
body became one blister Oh stupid stupid
no sunscreen none none out there all day
long yeah so I don't know if you know
UFOs are real but it's it's certainly
believable enough but it's not like the
the sky is empty it's filled with stars
so do you think now after speaking with
them that do you think we've had contact
it's hard to tell yes they came it's my
own opinion not for the listeners not
for anybody else just you when you're at
home and you're chilling do you think it
I don't know I really honestly don't
know I couldn't say yes or no I'm more
inclined now to think there's something
going on then I was before I met Lazar
and watch that documentary because I was
on that not that I was saying that
aliens are not real I think they're I
think there's a hundred percent life out
there let's just say that it's too big
right it just doesn't make any sense
that there isn't it's the question of
whether or not it ever has gotten here
before is the weird question and it's
also the problem is that you feel
foolish talking about it because so many
people who believe in it are foolish and
so many people who tell stories there's
their stories are foolish so you feel
foolish kind of going along with it
right
but I'm very careful about stuff like
that because I'm like just because
something makes you feel foolish doesn't
mean it's true
mm-hmm you know it isn't true yeah so I
definitely think there's a very high
likelihood that there's life out there
and it's entirely possible that
something's gotten here before but as to
whether or not something really has made
contact with people I don't know I'm in
if I would say like where's my scale
it's like probably 65 percent believe
yeah 35 percent going home especially
after talking oh my god yeah but what he
could he could have experienced
something that was an experimental
aircraft that they didn't want to tell
them right you never know man I mean I
just don't know what the tech look I'm a
[ __ ] like I don't understand physics at
all I have no knowledge of propulsion
systems or mathematics and I don't know
what the top of the field in propulsion
experts are capable of today I don't
know
there might be some [ __ ] that they're
working on that they've never really
perfected so they've never actually
implemented it in the battlefield or
something like that but they have some
sort of a drone that looks like it would
be filled with three-foot tall people
like these aliens that they described I
don't know they're not gonna fill you in
on that
if you think it's alien yeah fine it's
[ __ ] Haley exactly I mean who knows
what that was I mean they're taking this
guy who was a physicist from Los Alamos
labs who went to Caltech and they sent
him to these classes at MIT to learn
[ __ ] nuclear [ __ ] and then they try
to see if he can figure out how to back
engineer something they try to say that
doesn't mean it comes from another world
right it could have been a Russian thing
it could have been something that the
Germans figured out I don't know but I'm
more inclined to believe him than not
believe him yeah he didn't seem like he
was full of it exactly and just looking
at him he also didn't seem like he
wanted to be here he did he was just
like I'm done with this he was getting
migraines talking about it before he
even got out here is like I just kind of
tie I'm getting a migraine yeah and like
you know Jeremy was trying to talk them
into doing it like we're gonna be fine
George I mean uh Bob is important it's
really good to do this and we're gonna
be able to really get the story out but
I think more more people told me that
they got more out of the conversation
because it's just him talking not no
spooky music no edits right and you get
to see like he's honest about what he
knows and doesn't know
and when he would say like what do you
think about this is like maybe I don't
know right he wasn't a [ __ ] he
didn't seem rehearsed [ __ ] nothing
no what he was saying if he didn't
believe in that well at least himself
what are you saying I'd be [ __ ]
amazed and his story has not deviated in
30 plus years which you can't I've tried
to have me tell a story of something
that actually really did happen from 30
years ago and I probably told it a bunch
of different times oh well we started
the podcast it's hard to remain you my
memory varies day to day like some days
it's awesome and some days it's dog [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy how that works huh yeah
have you you've had a few concussions
right oh yeah same here
yeah I I have horrible memory
[Applause]